[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi 1er juillet début
d'une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale premier journal du mois sur tv 78
bienvenue dans cette édition voici les
titres le déplacement de plusieurs
sénateur des yvelines à l'aérodrome de
toussus le noble autour du président de
la chambre gérard larcher ils ont visité
le site aux outils innovants sur place
notamment un avion électrique capable de
voler pendant une heure
les vacances d'été approchent une
période pendant laquelle de moins en
moins de français partent avec la
pauvreté qui augmente chaque année est
le secours populaire français se
mobilisent afin de donner cette chance
aux familles nous en parlons en plateau
et puis ce projet devrait voir le jour
en 2021 dans le sud yvelines à la
station d'épuration de guy ville va
faire peau neuve elle sera raccordé à
une unité de méthanisation l'objectif
c'est de produire du biogaz qui sera
injecté dans le réseau à grdf
et puis l'adjoint au maire de maurepas
et conseiller communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines
erwan le gall sera également notre
invité il vient de prendre la tête du
comité des yvelines d'objectifs france
mais avant de débuter un policier placé
en détention par le parquet de
versailles il est soupçonné d'être
l'auteur de la trentaine de coups de
couteau qui a coûté la vie à un gardien
d'immeuble de 25 ans les faits se sont
produits dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi à joueurs qu'on chartrain est
les deux hommes avaient eu une relation
amoureuse le fonctionnaire a été mise en
examen pour homicide volontaire après
avoir reconnu les accusations elle le
motif du meurtre restent pour le moment
flou selon le parquet de versailles
scènes de violences urbaines à
saint-germain-en-laye une bagarre a
éclaté dans le quartier de bel air
samedi soir une rixe entre bandes
rivales de la ville et d'autres venus de
chanteloup-les-vignes une trentaine de
personnes seraient impliquées
au total les échauffourées ont fait sept
blessés trois personnes sont en état
d'urgence absolue et des barres de fer
des battes de baseball et des couteaux
ont été utilisés des affrontements qui
ferait suite à une autre rixe qui avait
éclaté la veille vendredi lors de la
soirée d'ouverture de la fête des loges
à saint-germain-en-laye lé sénateur des
yvelines accompagné donc du président du
sénat ont visité à l'aérodrome de
toussus le noble c'était en fin de
semaine dernière est découverte sur
place dès août des outils
innovant le récit de marylène yapi chez
nous une sénatrice au volet d'un
hélicoptère ce simulateur de vol permet
aux futurs pilotes de s'exercer
l'aérodrome de toussus le noble était le
premier à le mettre à disposition pour
la formation puisqu'il sera pas possible
en fait durant le vol réel est bien ou
ce qu'il n'aura pas été vu comme par
exemple des météos très dégradé dans
lesquels on ne se met pas sur des vols
réel on va pouvoir confronter le pilote
à ce type de météo pour le jour le
fameux au cas où
eh bien il aura déjà vu sur simulateur
de façon très réaliste et sera du coup
comment se comporter les sénateurs ont
passé la matinée à visiter cet aérodrome
et ses technologies autre exemple unique
en france l'avion électrique d'une
autonomie d'une heure cet avion
électrique il a un avantage
extraordinaire c'est qu'il ne fait pas
de bruit
il est blanc pourquoi parce que c'est
l'avion de l'onu c'est l'avion de la
paix avec les riverains tellement il est
silencieux notre sujet a tous eu et de
réduire les nuisances réduit les
nuisances sur l'environnement et donc
nous innovons avec des start up qui vont
générer de nouvelles motorisations
hybrides électriques
l'avion électrique des nouveaux usages
et surtout un dialogue qui conte à
favoriser au niveau local au niveau
territorial entre les riverains et les
usagers
un sujet qui répond aux problématiques
actuelles des sénateurs l'intérêt est
évidemment à quelques jours d'entamer
les discussions sur la loi climat
énergie eh bien nous sommes là sur un
secteur d'activité qui est
l'aéronautique qui est aussi un secteur
d'activité primordial pour la france et
qui va être absolument exemplaire dans
la recherche d'économies d'énergie
d'économies dé
nuisances le projet de loi énergie
climat a été adoptée à l'assemblée
nationale en première lecture le même
jour le texte arrivera en discussion au
sénat le 16 juillet toujours dans le
domaine de l'aéronautique la pme jacques
loupé clip participent à la production
de l'antenne du rafale l'avion de combat
de l'armée française cette usine
spécialisée dans les systèmes de
télécommunications est situé à trappes
découverte de l'activité des employés
sur ce site avec nicolas landry ce sont
des orfèvres de l'aéronautique ils sont
intégrateurs électronique câbleur ou
encore technicien polyvalent
au total 25 personnes sont employées
dans ses ateliers de la société boën
jacques loupé cli implantée à trappes
on travaille soit sur system système
antennes est en fait effectivement sur
des sur des produits qui v sont montés
sur l'aéronef
en fait ça ces appareils qui permettent
de communiquer soit avec une émetteurs
qui est situé soit en vols soit au sol
télécommunications et antennes pour
l'aéronautique la spécialité de cette
société en pleine croissance de son
activité elle recherche des nouveaux
collaborateurs notamment dans la
conception de câbles et l'intégration
électronique
il ya de la coupe de câbles et du
raccordement
donc il faut souder des connecteurs sûr
les prises bien spécifiques alors ici
nous avons des cartes à intégrer donc
devant des cartes vierges avec mise de
composants il faut connaître savoir
soudé et une bonne expérience aussi dans
les composants savoir lire et déchiffrer
aussi les plans après la production
vient une phase de contrôle notamment
pour les antennes c'est voir s'ils
fonctionnent ces voix se répondent aux
caractéristiques que vous demandés par
les clients c'est voir si si l'antenne
est correctement assemblé et intégré que
tout se passe bien les post
d'intégrateur électronique et de câbleur
sont à pourvoir dès à présent une page
politique à vernouillet ont voté ce
week-end pour le second tour de la
municipale partielle le maire sortant
udi pascal collado a été réélu pour
rappel le scrutin était organisé suite
aux nombreuses démissions dans le camp
de la majorité l'édile a récolté 54 %
des suffrages soit 458 voix devant marie
hélène lopez jollivet l'ancien maire
socialiste en lice à l'élection sous
l'étiquette de la république en marche
en troisième position le candidat s jean
pierre grenier totalise 15 % des voix
qualifié pour le second tour l'ancien
adjoint jean yves denis avait lui fait
le choix de se retirer pour ce second
tour et 35 5 % des électeurs ont voté
lors de ce second tour de la municipale
dernière séance avant les vacances d'été
le conseil communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines s'est réunie en fin
de semaine dernière à l'ordre du jour la
validation des comptes administratifs de
2018 est mais aussi le lancement d'une
concertation elle sera un préalable à la
restructuration de l'hyper centre ce
secteur autour de la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines à montigny le
bretonneux 70 mille voyageurs y
transitent chaque jour et le bassin
concentre 40 mille emplois plusieurs
opérations sont prévues pour le quartier
écouter ce centre qui aujourd'hui est
quand même extrêmement vieillissant et
qui du coup perd un peu en dynamisme et
en attractivité on a skywest qui peine à
se remplir à nouveau
on a un centre ville qui est très
original mais qui dont les bâtiments
vieillissent donc ça peut concerner la
venue du centre les cannelles le canal
urbain voilà toute cette zone là qu'il
ya vraiment besoin
je dirais d'un petit coup de un petit
coup de jeune un petit coup de neuf mais
à lui est justement conseiller
communautaire de saint quentin en
yvelines c'est erwan le gall montfort
histoire d également le premier adjoint
de la ville de maurepas vous êtes le
nouveau président du comité des yvelines
d'objectifs france passation officielle
qui a eu lieu ce vendredi à versailles
vous succédez à stanislas de la fois
comment vous accueilli cette nouvelle
fonction je suis très heureux j'étais
d'ailleurs à remercier cette année cela
ce de la fois parce que il a présidé
pendant un peu plus de deux ans ce
comité au niveau des yvelines et la
transmission c'est quelque chose
d'important et aussi de pour celui qui
lâche la fédération c'est quelque chose
aussi
kelly va aspirer notre nouvelle carrière
professionnelle ailleurs à l'étranger
pour le coup donc merci à lui pour cette
confiance
mais écoutez je prends ça avec beaucoup
de sérieux évidemment beaucoup de
hauteur c'est important
le département des yvelines et lorsque
on a cette responsabilité là on se rend
compte que c'est un grand département
avec des poches différente des poches
économique évidemment qui sur lesquels
je suis très très attentif comme vous le
savez mais aussi avec des enjeux
importants pour l'avenir puisqu'il ya
des chances des échéances municipales
qui arrive en 2020 donc nous allons agir
en ce sens il faut en parler dans un
instant alors le comité des yvelines a
été l'ancien fin 2010 cet objectif
france à un mouvement créé au niveau
national en 2014 par le chef
d'entreprise rafik smati représentent
une idéologie on est à droite pour cette
l'idéologie totalement alors c'est à
droite c'est viscéralement à droite dans
le sens libéral humaniste et surtout
conservateurs sur tout ce qui est
régalien et ce qui est très rassurant à
la tête de ce parti
rafik smati d'un chef d'entreprise bledi
s'épargner narc il a réellement les
pieds sur terre il ya un comité exécutif
autour de lui ou ce sont des gens de ces
deux de la société civile moi je vous
dire j'ai découvert ce parti depuis peu
puisqu'il ya une alliance avec le parti
libéral démocrate
j'ai rencontré toutes ces personnes
j'étais très cher mais au delà d'être
charmé j'ai vu aussi la puissance de
frappe de travail ça n'arrête jamais il
ya jamais de temps mort et surtout sur
un panel et des champs des possibles de
tout ce qui se passe en france et
international et est-ce qu'on est dans
une totale logique d'opposition à la
politique du gouvernement où vous pouvez
vous accorder sur sur certains sujets
avec cette politique
à ce jour ce qui est difficile de
s'accorder avec le gouvernement c'est
que pour le coup sûr certaines réformes
on a l'impression qu'ils ne vont pas
assez en profondeur donc il n'ya pas la
loi pâques par exemple il n'y a pas
assez de d'investissement du
gouvernement pour aller très loin dans
la réforme
donc du coup on propose autre chose la
loi pas qui est un exemple flagrant
ce qui se passe là actuellement sur
les les les taxes sur sur les
propriétaires avec la loi environnement
est quelque chose qui est complètement
ahurissant
tout ce qui se passe on n'entend pas
beaucoup parler ce qui est lié à la mer
et les îles qui vont être bradé comme ça
d'un revers de manche on n'en parle pas
beaucoup
tous ces sujets là on est évidemment en
opposition constructive avec des
propositions dont on devrait vous
écoutez d'ailleurs un peu plus
alors vous le disiez la stratégie
maintenant c'est de préparer ces
municipales qui arrive l'année prochaine
en 2020 il ya d'abord il ya d'ailleurs
des universités d'été 1 qui sont
programmés donc cet été pour pour le
parti quelle stratégie justement c'est
de présenter des candidats dans des
villes des yvelines peut-être nouer des
alliances avec des des mers peut-être
déjà en place alors sur un plan national
et donc les universités d'été tout ce
qui est lié aux municipales
objectif france c'est déjà au travail
c'est une machine qui est déjà parti
l'on sait avec des axes bien précis il y
a pour objectif sans liste d'annoncés la
france sur les yvelines et bien que tel
le travail il est un petit peu en l'état
à voir à déblayer
moi je souhaite rencontrer un maximum
d'élus de futurs candidats
peut-être voir des gens qui sont déjà et
vue et puis voir s'ils veulent adhérer
objectif france
il faut savoir qu'il n'ya pas de
consensus de mauvais consensus en tous
les cas c'est à dire il n'est pas
question pour nous de faire des grands
écarts pour obtenir des postes ça un
consensus par exemple sur votre ville
mort pas avec le mr en place
grégory garris y ait vraiment et c'est
là toute la différence et lorsqu'on est
délégué et au président une fédération
départementale
moi je regarde tout le département je
reviens pas sur ma propre vie d'accord
tout va bien vous avez une vision plus
globale sur le i leurs dépenses et déjà
c'était trop facile et je crois que sur
le département il ya il ya vraiment des
actions à mener
il y a des des élus qui est qui veulent
nous rejoindre tous les cars le vois je
rappelle que stanislas a repris la
fédération parce qu'il a lancé il y
avait 150 adhérents nous sommes à plus
de 450 en france nous sommes à 50 mille
adhérents et sympathisants
c'est une machine qui va certainement
grandir encore plus au niveau du
département
il faut pour cela être présent et
évidemment mais il reste six mois pour
voir ce que l'on peut faire
je vais être de ceux là est très actif
sur le territoire
merci à erwan mondiale président de donc
du comité des yvelines d'objectifs
france 70,8 merci d'être passé en
plateau c'est un projet un chantier qui
est très attendu dans la région de
rambouillet à une nouvelle station
d'épuration raccorder une unité de
méthanisation à cette structure
permettra notamment à d'injecter du
biogaz dans le réseau grdf les acteurs
du projet se sont retrouvés récemment
pour une visite du chantier le reportage
de nicolas baudry elle traite les eaux
usées des communes de rambouillet gazon
et vieille église
la station d'épuration de gay ville fait
peau neuve doublement des capacités de
traitement des eaux un chantier de deux
ans lancé par le syndicat intercommunal
de la région de rambouillet et derrière
c'est un bassin d'orage qui fera à 7600
mètres cubes
donc cette mission mais cube c'est un
bassin qui à faire plus de 30 mètres de
diamètre avec plus de 15 mètres 20
mètres de profondeur c'est un projet qui
est important puisque on va pouvoir
améliorer les la filtration des eaux
donc on va déjà doublé le volume de flux
donc là c'est quand même important
puisqu'on a passé de 8000 mètres cubes
jour à 16 milles 800 mètres cubes jour
en plus de cette rénovation une unité de
méthanisation va être raccordé à cette
station d'épuration une première en
ile-de-france objectif alimentaire en
biogaz entre 400 et 500 logements
les boues d'assainissement constitué de
bactéries de différentes natures de
matières organiques vont être amenés à
produire à générer du gaz vers du gaz
renouvelables produits sur le territoire
et qui sera ensuite réinjectée dans le
réseau de gaz naturel
coût total du projet vingt six millions
d'euros financés notamment par des aides
de l'état de la région et du département
et sur les fonds propres du syndicat
intercommunal de la région de
rambouillet
j avais pas eu les élus locaux le
président du cir
les trois maires de rambouillet le gazon
est dit l'église qui avait pas eu après
fait jaillir 2 préfet et un sous préfet
à rambouillet qui est aidée je crois que
le dossier ce matin il serait pas encore
à sa première pierre la nouvelle station
d'épuration de guerre il sera
opérationnel à la fin de l'année 2000 21
mai j'accueille à présent sur ce plateau
pascal rodier bonsoir on soit vous êtes
le président le secrétaire général
pardon du secours populaire des yvelines
alors avec les vacances qui approchent
votre fédération et est mobilisé 1 pour
mener des actions auprès des enfants des
familles aussi des seniors qui n'ont pas
cette chance de partir en congés cette
aide elle part d'un constat c'est que de
plus en plus de français ne peuvent pas
partir en vacances
si on considère que la population
augmente régulièrement en france on est
toujours à peu près à la même
statistique
un enfant sur trois qui partent pas en
vacances donc effectivement de problèmes
sont loin d'être résolus donc de plus en
plus de français qui ne peuvent pas
partir en vacances
vous disiez c'est aussi la pauvreté qui
gagne du terrain la population qui
augmente la peau la pauvreté qui
augmente oui et puis les vacances
deviennent de plus en plus un produit de
luxe terre qui compris dans le tourisme
qu'on qualifie social ça reste quand
même très onéreux il ya un mais
transport ne baisse pas aussi en termes
de coûts donc ça fait autant de freins à
la mobilité et donc aux loisirs pour les
personnes quoi et ces familles qui sont
privées justement de vacances ça
renforce leur sentiment d'exclusion bah
disons que ça fait partie c'est c'est
très symbolique les permettre à ces
enfants notamment ou permettre à sa
famille de d'avoir au moins un bol
d'oxygène être privé de ça c'est quelque
chose de très stigmatisant c'est un
petit peu comme au moment des fêtes de
noël ne pas pouvoir offrir un jouet à
son enfant bas là c'est pareil au moment
de l'été c'est synonyme de détente de
loisirs de repos et quand c'est pas
possible c'est vrai que c'est une
souffrance supplémentaire alors ce
chiffre en 2010 8 3262 personnes ont pu
être accompagné par le secours populaire
ont pu bénéficier des sorties a mis en
place par le secours populaire des
yvelines plusieurs actions à son sont en
place parmi les plus connus il ya
forcément les séjours en familles de
vacances des enfants qui sont accueillis
au sein de familles bénévoles
ça fait donc en fait on a des familles
bénévoles dans le département des
yvelines une dizaine aussi on a un
réseau national de fédérations et donc
on a sept fédérations partenaires qui
accepte en fait de faire les démarches
pour trouver des bénévoles dans leur
département qui accueilleront un ou deux
enfants pendant 15 jours ou trois
semaines
vous êtes encore à la recherche de
familles bénévoles alors là aux
étonnants ça commence à être un petit
peu on commence à être un petit peu sur
la fin il peut arriver que pour le mois
d'août
il puisse y avoir des dossiers qui se
débloquent mellal et franchement les
personnes qui se proposeront on gardera
un contact avec elle pour revenir vers
elle pour l'été 2020 ça fait un peu
court quand même pour il ya un petit peu
de démarches administratives à faire
malgré tout il y aurait aussi une action
qui revient aux halles il de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines c'est le
village copains du monde qui revient
donc pour la troisième fois ça sera du
12 au 19 juillet et qui mêle finalement
des enfants de plusieurs nationalités
c'est ça pour quoi
finalement ce séjour interculturel
pourquoi le mettre en place
c'est le projet du secours populaire ne
pas faire de distinction entre la
solidarité en france et dans le monde
déjà on a un réseau d'enfants solidaire
aussi qu'on appelle les copains du monde
et donc on prend le projet à la lettre
c'est à dire que pour être content du
monde le mieux c'est quand même de
rencontrer des enfants du monde et donc
on travaille avec des partenaires à
l'international cette année pour la
première fois on a des petits touareg
qui vont nous rejoindre
il y aura des enfants du portugal mais
aussi des enfants de la marne et donc
des yvelines et on cherche en fait créer
les conditions pour qu'il y ait des
liens qui perdurent en fait est qu'ils
échangent autour de la solidarité
mais c'est en même temps un séjour de
vacances est découverte lors d'autres
actions bien sûr les séjour en colonie
les séjours familiaux
il y aussi un accompagnement pour des
séjours auprès des seniors oui ça alors
ça fait quelques années maintenant qu'on
développe des séjours pour les seniors
isolés puisque on s'est rendu compte que
c'était une population ça fait
maintenant dix quinze ans qu'on que les
seniors reviennent de manière plus
visible dans les permanences d'accueil
du secours populaire donc on a très tôt
chercher à manifester notre solidarité
par rapport à ce public la solidarité
naturelle
donc on a commencé par les banques et
des cheveux blancs
normal les gens aux guinguettes en fait
c'est une valeur symbolique forte pour
nous pour nos aînés et puis depuis
quelques années grâce au soutien du
conseil départemental et de l'ancv ont
fait des petits séjours ou des
excursions d'une journée pour les
seniors donc la semaine dernière ils
étaient sur la côte d'opale
un groupe d'une dizaine et puis vers la
mi juillet il ya une sortie à deauville
puisque le 21 août ont fait la journée
des oubliés des vacances là pour les
enfants sur le même site on le
rappellera jamais assez le secours
populaire a bien sûr besoin de vos dons
pour financer ces actions vous pouvez
avoir toutes ces informations et données
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran merci pascal rodier c'est
moi qui vous remercie le critère général
du secours populaire des yvelines
vendredi dernier on commémorait le
centenaire de la signature du traité de
versailles document de paix signés en
1919 à l'issue de la première guerre
mondiale
pour l'occasion une centaine d'étudiants
américains en politiques et relations
internationales étaient présents lors
d'une cérémonie à versailles elle se
tenait au pied du monument pershing et
lafayette symbole de l'amitié
franco-américaine les propos sont
recueillis par mélanie poker et ils ont
souhaité venir faire une visite à ce
monument
parce que c'est un monument un peu
unique au monde dans lequel on voit deux
généraux qui conversent la relation
entre les dut se résume pourtant
spécifiquement mais non parce que il y à
beaucoup des problèmes entre l'europe et
les états unis
donc je crois que même ration est très
important c'est important pour des
nouveaux génération mondiales
historiques dont on voit maintenant est
comment en prêts à empêcher
il ya de la première on passe maintenant
à la seconde guerre mondiale pendant le
conflit l'ile-de-france a été notamment
à libérer par la 2e division blindée
américaine mais d'autres troupes aussi
ont participé à ce moment d'histoire
comme la 79e division d'infanterie
sa mémoire est entretenu par une
association ce week-end elles faisaient
une reconstitution au parc de diane aux
clayes-sous-bois mélanie poquet et yves
ibsen berger léger américain dès qu'il
est arrivé et avait des personnes dans
un bunker allemand qui est déjà long et
tiraient sur les américains logique 10
ans a fait un bond dans le temps ce week
end
allemands et américains face à face
comme il ya 75 ans en 1944 le parc de
diane est au coeur de la libération de
la ville
la 2e db en parallèle avec l'armée
américaine est venue au bois déclarée
puisque sur les rapports américains on
peut lire le bois déclinant les
clayes-sous-bois sur la période du 24 au
26 août pour libérer cette partie de
l'île de france elle l'association
recréer l'histoire de cette division
créée en 1917 et qui débarquent en
normandie entre le 12 et le 14 juin
une reconstitution possible grâce à une
vingtaine de passionnés pour se souvenir
donc dans les chars ils avaient une
rigueur
on a encore du très bonne initiative et
j'arrive mais bon j'ai eu l'occasion de
voir quelques stands est très
intéressant ça fait rappeler des valeurs
à certaines personnes et puis ça fait
rappeler qu'elle est mais qui sont
battus pour nous défendre et que c'est
vraiment c'est bien de reconstituer tout
ça on n'imagine pas en fait on n'arrive
pas se rendre compte que ça a pu exister
que maintenant vie tellement dans une
vie où on a quasiment tout tout nous est
donné bah on a peut-être tendance à
oublier qu'il ya des gens qui se sont
battus justement pour tout ça en fait
une période qui a laissé des traces dans
leur fuite les troupes allemandes
incendie le château pour ne laisser que
cette vue qui perdure encore aujourd'hui
[Musique]
et bien sûr la chronique du lundi avec
michael et le minot robond soir vous
nous présenter les résultats l'actualité
sportive du week-end un sport dont on ne
parle pas souvent nickel c'est le
crossfit le vélodrome qui était plein à
craquer ce week-end des sportifs ultra
musclé un rythme effréné la fièvre du
crossfit a gagné le vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines pendant
trois jours la structure a accueilli
pour la toute première fois
le crossfit french soit donne la
compétition a attiré près de 9000
personnes dans l'enceinte
on écoute l'un des organisateurs au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude mois
sur glee j'ai fait ce genre de boulot
dans toutes ces pays les infrastructures
ici soit exceptionnel la flexibilité de
l'équipe aussi nous permettent de
concerts on accourt c'est un stade à
l'extérieur on a un village partenaires
mais comment se déroulait la compétition
alors plusieurs catégories étaient au
programme des moins de 18 ans plus de 50
ans total 540 participants venus de 47
pays se sont affrontés à travers une
dizaine d'épreuves qui met à la fois
force endurance précision et vitesse
on écoute les réactions même ma
catégorie eric saade très gros niveau
donc
c'est un honneur d'être ici c'était
vraiment un événement réussi pour moi
c'est le maire événements en europe qui
disent pas du look très haut très haut
je pensais pas que ce soit si haut
niveau ça nous pousse même nous les plus
petits pour redevenir qui croyais plus
fort donc très très gros niveau est très
intéressant
je pensais pas avoir autant de monde ici
et c'est vraiment bien ça montre que
crossfit a beaucoup d'importance
les meilleurs ont remporté un chèque de
dix mille euros et le droit de
participer au crossfit games
l'équivalent de la coupe du monde de la
discipline
mais le succès rencontré cette année les
organisateurs discutent déjà d'un
éventuel retour au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines a décidé mot
dans cette chronique la part belle à des
pratiques originales une compétition
après le crossfit avait aussi une
compétition insolite
c'est ça une équipe versaillaise baptisé
titanic a participé aux red bull jourdan
vol le week-end dernier à lyon une
compétition délurée où les participants
doivent propulsé à leur ovni du haut
d'une plate-forme de six mètres après
une petite chorégraphie et jack et rose
d'un jour sont ensuite notés par un jury
regardez cet extrait de leur compétition
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
ils ont finalement terminé à la 14e
place sur 32
comme quoi comme quoi merci michael on
vous retrouve bien sûr dans votre
émission dans un instant le 7-8 sport
sur tv 78 avant de refermer ce journal
ces formes géométriques apparu dans un
champ à ce marché
samedi c'est ce qu'on appelle un crop
circle 1 pour certains c'est la trace du
passage d'extraterrestres sur notre
planète mais d'après nos confrères de
7,8 actu est la réalisation serait bien
d'origine humaine tracé par des
professeurs de sciences yvelinois pour
une leçon de géométrie soyez donc
rassurés
michael vous l'êtes je sais pas de
débarquement d'extraterrestres encore
prévues dans les yvelines
c'est la fin du set 8 journal belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]